IT'S GOING TO BE A HUGE YEAR
FULL OF MASSIVE DEVELOPMENTS AND
LOTS OF LIES.
JOINING US, THE RANKING MEMBER
OF THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE,
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES OF
CALIFORNIA.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
ALL OF THESE GOP INVESTIGATORS
STARTING WITH RATCLIFFE AND
PEOPLE LIKE LINDSEY GRAHAM AND
YOURSELF, YOU'RE SAYING THERE'S
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS THAT WILL
EXPOSE THE MISUSE, THE KNOWING
MISUSE OF THE STEELE DOSSIER,
ESPECIALLY AS RELATES TO THE
FISA APPLICATIONS.
CAN YOU TELL US MORE?
>> I'LL START WITH, WE WANT THIS
INFORMATION OUT.
LET ME SAY IN TWO TRANCHES OF
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
NUMBER 1, THERE'S WHAT WE CALL
INFORMATION ON PAPADOPOULOS THAT
WE BELIEVE IS EXCULPATORY THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN OUT THERE.
LET'S SET THAT ASIDE.
THE OTHER SET IS --
>> Sean: SLOW DOWN.
WHERE IS THAT EXCULPATORY
EVIDENCE?
>> IT RESTS AT THE FBI.
WE'VE BEEN ASKING FOR IT TO BE
DECLASSIFIED.
THAT'S ALL I CAN SAY ABOUT IT.
IT'S EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE THAT
SHOULD BE PROVIDED TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
ON THE FISA APPLICATION,
REMEMBER, YOU HAVE COMEY WHO HAS
CALLED THIS A MOSAIC.
SO COMEY'S MOSAIC.
REMEMBER WHEN WE CAME OUT WITH
OUR MEMO THAT BROUGHT FORWARD
THE FACT THAT THEY HAD USED THE
CLINTON PAID-FOR DOSSIER, THE
DIRT, OPPOSITION RESEARCH, AND
THEN THEY LEAKED THAT TO PRESS
OUTLETS AND PICKED UP THE PRESS
REPORTS AND USED IN THE FISA
APPLICATION.
COMEY SAID IT WAS A MOSAIC,
THERE'S MORE INFORMATION THERE.
THERE IS MORE INFORMATION THERE
THAT IS EQUALLY AS BAD AS USING
OPPOSITION RESEARCH.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THIS: IS
IT TRUE -- LET'S START WITH THE
FIRST FISA APPLICATION -- THAT
THE BULK OF INFORMATION WAS THE
STEELE DOSSIER BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR BY HILLARY CLINTON, FULL OF
RUSSIAN LIES?
WAS THAT THE BULK OF THE FISA
APPLICATION?
>> IT IS THE BULK, BUT REMEMBER
WHAT WE BELIEVE THE REST OF IT
IS, THAT FILLS OUT COMEY'S
MOSAIC, IS THE TRUE DEFINITION
OF THE INSURANCE POLICY.
REMEMBER THE TALK OF THE
INSURANCE POLICY BY STRZOK AND
PAGE ON THE TEXT MESSAGES.
WOE BELIEVE THAT INSURANCE
POLICY IS NOT JUST ABOUT
INVESTIGATING THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
WE BELIEVE IT'S TO ENSURE THAT
THEY WERE ABLE TO GET THE FISA
WARRANT ON CARTER PAGE SO THEY
COULD GO IN AND LOOK AT THE
E-MAILS IN THE CAMPAIGN.
>> Sean: SO CARTER PAGE IS BEING
USED TO -- IT'S NO SMALL DEAL.
BUT THEY VIOLATED HIS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS TO GET A
BACK DOOR TO ALL THINGS TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, THE TRUMP TRANSITION
AND EVEN THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY,
CORRECT?
>> IT'S HORRIBLE WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE TO MANY AMERICANS.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS ABOUT THIS,
SEAN.
THIS IS -- WE'VE BEEN LIVING FOR
THREE YEARS WITH THE PERVERTED
FANTASIES OF GLEN SIMPSON AND
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN TALKING
ABOUT PEE TAPES.
THIS IS GROSS STUFF.
YOU SHOWED THE CLIP OF BIDEN.
WHEN YOU AMERICANS OUT THERE
SAYING THAT I THINK THAT
VLADIMIR IS CONTROLLING
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WE CAN'T LEAVE FOR SIX MORE
YEARS OF THIS.
THOSE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN POISONED
BY THE FANTASIES OF GLEN SIMPSON
AND THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
AT SOME POINT, THE FBI AND
FUSION NETWORK INTERTWINE AND
THEY WERE WORKING IN CONJUNCTION
ON THIS.
THAT'S WHAT THE U.S. ATTORNEY
DURHAM IS SUPPOSED TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF.
>> Sean: IS IT TRUE AT THE TOP
OF THE FISA APPLICATIONS AS
CONGRESSMAN RATCLIFFE HAS SAID,
IT SAYS IN BIG LETTERS
"VERIFIED?"
IS THAT PART?
>> EVERYTHING IS SUPPOSED TO BE
VERIFIED.
ONE THING THAT JOHN SOLOMON
DEPARTMENT GET COVERAGE ON WHAT
HE BROKE LAST WEEK THAT YOU
TALKED ABOUT ABOUT THIS HIGH
LEVEL STATE DEPARTMENT PERSON
THAT MET WITH STEELE THAT IS
QUESTIONABLE.
WHAT NOBODY IS PAYING ATTENTION
TO HERE, THREE YEARS WENT BY,
BUT YET ONE MEETING WITH
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, A HIGH
RANKING STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL IN OCTOBER OF 2016,
WEEKS BEFORE THEY WENT TO THE
FISA COURT, YOU HAD MORE
VERIFICATION DONE BY THAT STATE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL THAT SAID
WAIT A SECOND.
THE RUSSIANS DONE HAVE A
CONSULATE IN MIAMI.
OKAY?
>> Sean: YEAH.
ALL RIGHT.
SO LET ME -- WHEN CHRISTOPHER
STEELE IS QUESTIONED UNDER EAST
IN GREAT BRITAIN IN THAT
INTERROGATORY AND HE DOESN'T
STAND BY HIS OWN DOSSIER, SAID I
HAVE NO IDEA IF IT'S TRUE, WE
KNOW FROM THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL THAT WARNED EVERYBODY
THAT THIS WAS POLITICAL, BECAUSE
HE HAD A DUE DATE BEFORE
ELECTION DAY, BUT DOESN'T THAT
REPRESENTEDER THAT DOCUMENT
UNVERIFIABLE IF HE WON'T STAND
BY IT, I DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF
ITS TRUE, 50/50 RAW
INTELLIGENCE.
ANYBODY THAT SIGNED A FISA
APPLICATION WAS SIGNING ON TO
SOMETHING THAT THEY COULDN'T
HAVE POSSIBLY VERIFIED, CORRECT?
>> A LOT OF THINGS THAT DON'T
MAKE SENSE ABOUT THIS.
ONE THING WE KNOW NOW FOR SURE
BECAUSE OF THIS REVELATION IS
THAT THE FBI DID KNOW THAT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS TALKING
TO PEOPLE IN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT.
THEY KNEW ONE BIG PART OF IT
BECAUSE SUPPOSEDLY THE MONEY WAS
BEING FUNNELED THROUGH THIS
RUSSIAN CONSULATE IN MIAMI THAT
DOESN'T EXIST.
THE FBI NEW GOOD AND WELL THAT
STEELE HAD A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
I'LL SAY SOMETHING ELSE ABOUT
STEEL.
IT'S CALLED THE STEELE DOSSIER.
IT'S CLINTON OPPOSITION
RESEARCH.
STEELE HAD A VERY SMALL ROLE IN
ACTUALLY CRAFTING THIS.
THESE REALLY WITH THE PERVERTED
FANTASIES OF GLEN SIMPSON WITH
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN SAYING WHAT
CAN WE DRAW UP AND SPREAD LIES
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND FEED
TO THE FBI AND GO AN
INVESTIGATION ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED HERE.
>> Sean: COMEY IS ACTING CUTE
WITH THE WORDS SPY.
HE JUST SIGNED A WARRANT TO SPY
ON THE THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
CARTER PAGE.
I KNOW HE THINKS HE'S A SUPER
PATRIOT AND SMARTER THAN WE
SMELLY WALMART PEOPLE.
BUT IS THERE ANY DOUBT IN YOUR
MIND THAT THOSE THAT SIGNED
THAT -- THOSE FISA APPLICATIONS
KNEW DARN WELL THAT THAT
INFORMATION WAS FALSE AND
UNVERIFIABLE?
>> THE PEOPLE BEHIND THAT WERE
BUILDING THOSE FISA APPLICATIONS
HAD TO HAVE KNOWN THE PROBLEMS
WITH STEELE.
NOW WE KNOW.
WE HAVE NOW EVIDENCE, RIGHT?
WE HAVE A SMOKING GUN BECAUSE WE
HAVE E-MAILS NOW ACCORDING TO
JOHN SOLOMON'S REPORT.
WHEN YOU MOVE PASSED THAT FOR
SURE BY THE SECOND AND THIRD AND
FOURTH RENEWAL OF THE FISA, THAT
IS --
>> Sean: THEY KNEW THE FIRST
ONE.
WARNED TWICE.
BRUCE OHR WARNED THEM AND THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WARNED
THEM.
>> THEY KNEW IN THE FIRST ONE,
YES.
BUT MORE PEOPLE BECOME
CONTAMINATED WHEN YOU LOOK AND
THE SECOND, THIRD AND FOURTH.
IMAGINE THAT AS AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN.